- Es ist wichtig, auf andere Menschen
Rücksicht zu nehmen.
Es ist wichtig, Versprechen zu halten.
- Nico?
Nico?
Kannst du mir bitte ein Putztuch bringen?
- Es ist sinnvoll,
einen Putzplan zu erstellen.
- Nico?
Ich brauch' ein Putztuch.
Das ist ein Geschirrtuch.
Ich brauche ein Putztuch
oder ein Wischtuch. Hier.
Putztuch.
- Hey! Ihr macht sauber?
- Ähm, ja, also, ich mach' hier eigentlich
seit Wochen ständig sauber.
Was ist denn eigentlich aus
unserem Putzplan geworden?
Hä? Ich fand die Idee super,
die Arbeit aufzuteilen.
Und eine Schwangerschaft ist übrigens
kein Grund, nicht mitzuhelfen.
- Ich finde schon.
- Ich finde nicht.
Nico und ich, wir … also ich …
mach' hier fast die ganze Arbeit alleine.
- Ich darf mich aber nicht anstrengen.
- Dann kaufen wir doch einen Saugroboter.
- Jetzt fang nicht an,
wieder von diesem Roboter zu erzählen.
Nico, alles okay?
- Keine Ahnung. Selma antwortet
seit gestern Abend nicht mehr.